depuis des mois il rêvait de leurs
vacances
vous suivez fièrement leur petit maillot
de bain sur la plage se tartiner de
crème solaire pour le moment le maillot
est toujours au fond de la valise et
c'est à d'autres équipements qui semble
plus âpre et rude comme toujours
l'imperméable et les bottes quand même
au cas où la pluie qui sapent le moral
au camping municipal des nouveaux
arrivants font grise mine
leurs vacances serait-elle déjà gâché un
peu aussi quand même parce que la plage
c'est pas évident en plus ces 14 juillet
aujourd'hui le feu d'artifice ça va
peut-être pas être la grande joie pour
tout le camping ou presque
l'activité du jour s'est défilé du 14
juillet à la paix voilà on va voir on
viens de regarder le défilé mais il
pleut à paris encore plus qu'ici ce coin
ça me console non non un malheur de l'un
fait pas l'autre malheureux aussi ce
restaurateur au bord de la plage un
serveur et vos clients
ce trafic qu'est ce qu'on fera pour les
dernières c'est encore pire
deux autres personnes qui ont personnes
tous la plage se promènent à rien mais
ils restent ici en quelques heures le
temps qu changé de mains ces propos
on se laisse facilement aux